my question about their statistics on
rape culture um don't you think that
maybe a lot of women who experiences
don't want to come forward if you don't
want to give you an example on in your
ear Jewish so you know Long Island New
York there is a piece of Long Island New
York where there's a pediatrician oh no
oh no I'm waiting near the case not
everyone in Long Island is Jewish but
don't worry I don't think you're an
anti-semite gargling ah but more
importantly in this town I'm a king for
in that way there was a few people that
he molested and then more people came
forward and it came out being like
dozens and dozens and like there's this
whole escapade where people didn't even
say nice even so other people came
forward yes so don't you think that
maybe people are scared to come forward
and that it's possible that those
statistics could be not entirely happy
okay so it's possible the statistics are
somewhat low but the idea that they are
244 low out of 250 is wrong right so you
see there's a vast difference between
0.6 percent rape rate and 25 percent
rate rate so yes if you're asking are
there women are there men who are raped
who are intimidated about coming forward
of course that's true and of course we
need to make it easier for people to
come forward and report rape I think by
the way that it is also very important
that in cases of rape we get a that we
propel an evidentiary standard because
when I'm talking about you have to
castrate or kill people they better damn
well be guilty right I want to make sure
that the people who are convicted are
certainly are guilty but that said I
think that one of the great tragedies is
that there are so many people who are
raped you don't come forward and then
they talk later about you know the rates
that they've experienced the world would
be a lot better place if we could
encourage those people to come forward
if they did come forward I won't rapists
in jail I don't want them out on the
street so when people say rape culture
my problem is it's just you think I
don't know what that means who in the
United States is Pro rape I need to hear
like what like who out there really
other than Bill Clinton
I think come on II wouldn't say though
that I mean we're on quad campus I see a
colossal amount like guys taking
advantage of girls I don't think they're
thinking oh let me go rape this girl
couldn't you say that there's a very
close match between I think there's an
irresponsibility culture I'm not sure
that there's a rape culture and what I
mean by that is that you know what
you're talking about if first of all if
there is a culture again I don't know
who's out there saying rape is good but
I think there are people out there
saying that getting drunk and having sex
with random people is good and if that
leads to a higher rape right if there's
a correlation there that's a problem
obviously but what is the reason I don't
like the term rape culture is not
because I'm Pro rape it's because I'm
anti rape
I think that we should make very clear
that rape needs to be stopped but the
idea that everybody out there is is on
the verge of raping women which is sort
of what rape culture suggests is just
not true as a slander against men
[Applause]